this is a production of Cornell
University
Oh so thank you for coming today today
I'm going to do a talk that is a little
bit different than the technical talk I
gave in plant breeding a couple weeks
ago if you're watching on YouTube it's
maybe in one of the channel of videos
around this portion of your screen but
here today so I just want to talk about
some things we doing more than the art
side of breeding and some of the trends
and things we are looking to influence
to try to maybe give us some more
opportunities in what different crops we
can breed and so in plant breeding much
of what we do aligns with some grand
challenge questions feeding a global
population look at sustainability and
various facets climate change addressing
malnutrition throughout the world and
being able to keep up with evolving and
dispersing pests and pathogens that are
coming to challenge their crops and
there's a lot we do to directly address
these but in the process the the topic I
want to integrate today and we'll
explore in a couple different stories
some you're familiar with some might be
new is reducing waste in the breeding
process itself and not necessarily
looking at directly in the waste stuff
there's a lot of the squash that is left
over from our breeding program that ends
up going to the food pantry a lot from
trials we've been distributing the
leftovers from our genomic selection
populations around before Thanksgiving
so there's some direct ways but there's
also just some wasted opportunity in the
breeding process so that's one of the
main things I want to talk today and
really bring it back to the market class
concepts and demands of the marketplace
and to see if we can influence them we
can maybe influence how much progress we
can make and so the one of the main
challenges we work on and so this pest
this is a striped cucumber beetle is a
specialist herbivore feeding on Kubik
crops
you've probably heard from myself or my
student Lauren about how these beetle
just are specialized to feed on cucurbit
crops
they will lay their eggs at the base
they sequester some of the bitter
compounds in the plants used for their
own defense and if you have a winter
like we did last year or it looked like
we might have this year remains to be
seen we really didn't have that killing
from the really low temperatures to
really really reduce the butyl
populations and so there were swarms
everywhere and it was one of the most
challenging year for a lot of Kubik
growers that i've heard of and we're
just really thinking about climate
change and how those mild winters are
gonna intensify this problem so from the
reading perspective you know what can we
do and it's important to think about it
from a breeding plant breeding
perspective because as we look at some
of the chemical controls we have and
we've relied on breeding for resistance
to these insect pests and probably many
insect pests has lost a lot of attention
because of the cheapness and efficacy of
a lot of the pesticides we've had that
really do a really good job of
eliminating this pests the challenge and
the increasing scrutiny these pesticides
have is as you can see these insects are
attracted to the flowers there's a lot
of nectar in the flowers pollen protein
and you know that's also where the bees
are feeding and so as we're starting to
scrutinize neonicotinoids and their use
and how them there might be some
interaction with pollinator health
having some alternative and if we can
find one within the plant that would be
an ideal solution and we initially
approach this how many people have
before starting to do some field assays
of beetle damage where you can see there
are some plants and some plots that are
green and thriving and other plants
where it's noticeably well the plants
are rather absent the bee it'll just
devour them to the ground and as we
sorted through this you know we
definitely focused originally on those
extremes and that's why we've shown a
few times before so on the top we have
success PMS straight next summer squash
developed here at Cornell by my predator
and also very popular in organic systems
it's an organic seed is broadly
available this one on the bottom you see
a golden zucchini and this is a crop
where the beetles really prefer it
they've d foliated it and also in the
process the plants that escape that have
gotten bacterial will and then will die
from that and there's been a lot of
people have looked at from the
recommendations in trying to figure out
so what can a grower plant that's really
going to be able to give them a crop
that will be less vulnerable to these
beetles and they've often looked at
different cultivars that are popular at
the time
we took it one step further and looking
at all the different market classes and
the amount of defoliation damage we saw
there's definitely a trend and you can
order the market classes through
increased damage and further where the
biology really comes into play is it
turns out there is a really nice
demarcation in the middle where of all
these squash you eat pumpkins
jack-o'-lanterns pumpkins acorn squash
zucchini coca Zell there's two different
subspecies two separate domestication
events and there's a clear distinction
in preference based on the best same
subspecies klein so on the top you see
the summer squash that are getting very
little damage a member of the subsidy
fanon and the bottom the zucchini a part
of the people people and so how this
relates to some of the market class
questions is one thing it really comes
down to those two extremes I was showing
genetically they're very different
there's two the beetles they're very
different
to consumers there's still different but
you know to what degree could they
substitute right so here is that yellow
summer squash on the far side is a
golden Cikini you have two yellow summer
squash fruits once you put a less almac
marinade and put them on the grill you
know how different might they be but
still there is driving the marketplace
to have these two different market
classes
and use them differently or at least the
demand to have access to both and indeed
the zucchinis tend to be a little bit
more preferred in the marketplace which
is again a question that comes back to
the sustainability because the yellow
summer squash
they have multiple flowers print per
note are actually much higher yielding
so you have it's kind of the more
sustainable choice okay and further
looking at all of the different market
classes here will you see if her
breeders off and what we do is to try to
be able to continue to make progress and
most rapidly many people do conservative
crosses they you seldom see crosses
across the subspecies and often you'll
see crosses within a market class and so
the amount of gain you can stand to make
is you know quite narrow quite
restricted but we have started doing
many of those crosses and so here's a
population between those two contrasting
squash I showed and you can see the
selection process here after lauren has
gone to the field and vacuumed up
thousands of beetles to put into these
cages and you can see there's some clear
preference differences as we have these
segregating populations some plants
defoliated some plants still have you
know fledgeby's full intact leaf and so
here so we're doing a cross between the
two and one question we're going to have
is so at what point are we going to need
are we going to be close enough to a
golden zucchini and in this time they
were doing the breeding - you know what
extent can yellow summer school our
substitute in the marketplace it's
really a market class drive we're doing
here friends so in terms of being able
to have just a good summer squash it's
well there's already exists the true
alternative that we are very excited to
be starting to work on and it's
something where I myself need to be kind
of persuaded down this road to explore
this is an Italian summer squash this is
a trombone Chi know summer squash they
are part of the most shot of species so
rather than being between those two
subspecies its own species
and they they can be used as a winter
squash the butternut squash you might be
enjoying this week in addition they can
be used as a summer squash in our work
to look at some of the climate change
aspects we often have trials in the
southeast because that's a good
predictor of the climate we might have
to come and the growers are working
through many of those challenges now and
one of the key differences that makes
this from an chino more sustainable is
nearest to me on the right you have a
zucchini stem it is hollow and very
susceptible to squash vine borers they
get in that passageway they're very hard
to control once they get in on your left
you have the solid stem of one of these
mo shadow species so just naturally much
more resistant to the vine boards
because they can't really burrow in and
just have a subway system through the
plant but this was the Trump and Chino
is an heirloom there's a lot of room to
improve and so this is where we started
to get some of the great input from the
team at Blue Hill and chef Dan barber as
we look through to see so what are the
characteristics we do need to preserve
in these from and Chino squash as we
start to breed with them and then
understanding so how can they best be
displayed in a dish and so you have some
different uses where you find the
Tremonti no they're much more delicious
than a zucchini they have Laver and so
if you've ever thought about where its
flavor in zucchinis well there are some
classes that they do have some great
flavor but also here in a trump and
Chino you get a lot flavor there's a lot
of density to it and this became a very
popular offering there and this model is
something that we have we're very
optimistic for how it work with the
trombone Chino because of the great
success we've had in the past and so the
honey nut squash you know hopefully no
one enjoy now is here in the bottom
corner and it wasn't something that
originally took off because it looked
different than it's on the marketplace
the Trump and Chino is going to look
different than this
squash the growers we talked to that's
one of their major concerns is how are
they actually going to get in the
marketplace it's a crop they know that
works for them but so how do you get
that culinary trend to catch on well the
the chef is the key so Honey Nut is a
small squash it has a built-in ripeness
indicator you can tell when it's fully
ripe that will change from a green to an
orange rind and is much more delicious
at least I will tell you than any other
flutter nut squash you'll have and the
key within that is that it has a cross I
was done many years ago dick Robinson at
Geneva started the process Miley John
continued it but it's a cross between a
butternut squash and the Buttercup
squash and that yielded the honey nut
squash which that talked about some of
the technical aspects before this is an
exciting crop both for how good it is
itself and it's much sweeter much
smoother texture then it was much of
that to the Buttercup in its pedigree
but also it has about twice the
beta-carotene more than three times the
lutein again as much alpha carotene so
it's really a neutral and antioxidant
nutrient powerhouse there and it's also
been serving the basis for further
genomic selection work we've been doing
the the reason it had some challenges
getting into the marketplace and the
kind of what's helping it now is that
its distinctive right and so it's
smaller has the orange rind if you're
growing your garden starting out dark
green so it took a while for that to
catch on it was getting that popularized
so then when it did catch on now we're
getting a privilege it's normally
reserved for apple cultivars where it's
sold by name in the grocery store that
had the SKU code that's specific to it
and so all the work we've done in Vienna
crates on it's really delicious has is
identifiable so consumers can go back to
find it experience and they can know
when it's ripen at its peak is all
coming together and this is something we
can do hopefully for many of the other
they work on the ripeness indicators
that trend were putting into all our
squash it's really hard to tell whether
a butternut squash is ripe or not
otherwise and also just an example of
one of the trends that we now know we
can drive a couple others where we are
recreating some crops that don't
necessarily fit in the existing molds is
our work with some purple snow peas and
so this is exciting to us for the color
there's a of course in the antioxidant
boost that comes with the anthocyanins
and associated flavonoids but these are
a little different and they're a little
different because they're not a
perfectly straight and so in pee
breeding a lot of effort has gone into
making the pods perfectly straight the
challenge we find when it comes to you
know beyond incorporate them into food
is whether you have a few of those in a
stir fry it works very well it's pretty
they mix in but once you start to add
more than a certain amount they start to
look a little bit like the truckloads of
firewood that might have been dropped
off at your houses so there's just you
have that pile of them and they all just
kind of stack together these as you can
see have a curl to them they have this
wavy nature that actually is really cool
initially because it gives them loft and
so they just have much more presence
appearance on the plate and as you are
starting to work with them share it it
is actually just something that's more
interesting to work with and present in
addition to all the work we've done on
getting the flavor to be sweet and
overcome some of the stringency of those
purple flavors there's some often some
bitterness and astringency associated
with the accumulation anthocyanins and
crops the other example where we just
having fun and creating new types of in
this case peppers and so just trying to
do some things to really increase the
market appeal you see those little
snacking peppers that you'll see
increasingly on the vegetable trays you
have a gathering it's great to see that
they are one
the first one first vegetables to go off
the tray but we can think we can
increase the consumption even more the
vitamin C content in these is also
through the roof and so there's this
novelty and looking at flavor and
quality and then also being able to
capture some insect disease resistance
with the Trump in Chino there's also
work we do on another pathogen q Corbett
downy mildew this there's a lot of this
work I do with Chris smart and the
resistance we had to downy mildew it
wasn't really an issue for many growers
for quite a few years for a few decades
there was some resistance and been bred
into held really well the challenge we
faced is we started to get some new
races some new strains of the pathogen
that we're starting to overcome the
existing resistance and so you'll have
some telltale symptoms on a cucumber
leaf and then once it occurs an area it
rapidly the fully it's the crop and so
on the bottom left you can see just a
little bit over just ten days of disease
progress for this pathogen so once it
moves in you go from having a productive
crop to nothing very quickly now all the
downy mildew resistant cultivars that
were out on the market you know the
pathogen has overcome their resistance
and toward that we've hard to do some
this isn't working Peter Oh jumbo in
North Carolina and looking at how we can
track the pathogen you know one thing
you can see it's going to retrieve to
the east coast we can watch how it moves
through the year and with some special
emphasis with has been in from the major
area than the Carolinas in Michigan
where a lot of the production happens
and then up in our area in New York it
always often arrives later but this is a
pathogen that's being dispersed it is
probably overwintering in protected
structures around Michigan where as we
try to have this global continual supply
of cucumbers year round that leads to
we're growing cucumbers year round in
the pad
the gin is present year-round and
especially as tropical storms move up
the East Coast as those increase we
often get much more and sooner the
dispersal of downy mildew up the coast
and so you know this is a pathogen that
then interacts with some of our food
system issues on a large scale and the
most direct way you would interact with
it is if you were growing cucumbers in
the fall you'll see that your plants
just quickly die in all the regional
local food markets all the cucumber's
are lost at some point in the fall not
just because of you know the frost of
the season is ending up but you know
this passage is moving in and the
fungicides are losing their efficacy as
it continues to rapidly evolve so we've
been excited when we can be able to have
a major change in disease resistance for
this so our two most resistant varieties
on the top so varieties that are now
commercially available talked about now
compared to some of the other options
growers had as they turn to something
that had improved downy mildew
resistance or was just one of these
heirlooms you know a typical crop they
had been cucumber called bard they had
been growing and excitingly also and as
I showed you that map of how downy
mildew is coming up the East Coast this
is a trial of the beautiful location our
collaborator Janine Davis has in North
Carolina and you can see in the
foreground as downy mildew starts to
move in and take out our cucumber and
melon pots behind it you can see the
this site I was overjoyed to see as I
pulled in is the arrows show you the
green patches so these are our resist
and cucumber cultivars so it's bred in
New York but it's not as something that
works in New York it's something that is
also really holding up in some of the
severe disease pressures in some of the
main cucumber producing regions in the
nation and with this and one of the the
back stories with it that is exciting is
often is people think about the time
line four introducing a new cultivar so
for us this new downy mildew resistant
line 401 it's something that I've showed
in some other talks is a much higher
yielding when downy mildew is there of
course it's still alive but also has
some competitive earliness in the
initial cross we did in 2012 to take
what was a later but robust disease
resistant breeding line this a 264 cross
it to Dasher which is one of the most
commonly grown slicing cucumbers around
that cross in 2012 we were doing
selections in the field in 2013 we can
have the benefit of a couple of
generations a year using the greenhouse
face we had a a selection that we were
really confident about in 2015 was out
in a couple of trials as a really
preliminary stage the our release just
came out last week and so the
publication of its existence is just
coming out and also there's a seed
company that has it licensed did a see
production this summer and so this is
something that we started the process in
2012 it's going to be available to
growers or the specific focus on the
southeast where they really need it most
next summer and so this is a really
rapid response system where is it really
fully finished can we do more with it
certainly we're going to keep working on
it that's in part why we're giving them
these numbered lines and not names yet
because these are still going to be
works in progress but that doesn't mean
that a grower can't really benefit from
having this tool on their farms
now right and so we've just continued to
release things as soon as we have
something we know is an improvement it's
hard to fast-track that get it out to
the growers and so and while that is
something we're proud of and seems fast
on that scale there's also something
that could be even faster some of the
sources for downy mildew resistance
we're using are things that are our
cultivars that are well know their
cultivars depending on where you are in
the world
that was the seat that was the key to
much of our resistance breeding is
taking different cultivars that had
moderate resistance bringing that
together and getting an even higher
level of resistance and looking through
some of these cultivars you'll see
there's some Chinese cultivars that are
in growing in parts of the world where
these pathogens are endemic
there are also Indian cultivars that are
also being grown in parts of the world
with some of these pathogens are endemic
and so these are existing cultivars that
are fit with existing cuisines around
the world and while we can spend a lot
of time adapting these doing some
breeding to be able to kind of take that
resistance and intrigue resset into some
of the market classes we enjoy there's
also the potential for these to be
enjoyed right now and to help to
diversify to share more broadly this how
well they might do the many have
excellent yield these in high tunnel
open field trials with them and the
flavor is great sometimes the flavor is
different sometimes it needs to be used
differently in the kitchen but these are
still cucumbers that can be grown now
and enjoyed at least while we are at
certain times of season when it's
difficult to grow the other cultivars or
while we are continuing to make it into
to do the breeding process to introduce
the resistance into the market classes
we enjoy and so that's really looking at
some of those aspects of the breeding
process and where we can interact
another opportunity and that has
increasingly drawn attention so here's a
study by the NRDC is just looking at the
amount of produce that is harvested and
then just never really makes it into you
know well into our diets and never makes
it into our bellies and a variety of
reasons sometimes it is oversupply and
so there's often to make sure you a
grower can meet a contract they will
produce more just to make sure they can
have that supply
much of what's over produced my end up
in a landfill something that doesn't
look like you might be expecting to fit
that market class concept might end up
in a landfill and so as we've been
starting to look at some of the
different ways we can improve this again
we've taken the lead from our great
collaborator chef Dan barber and this is
his salad collaboration with sweet
greens that's been a big inspiration to
us and how we start to think about also
how we can change some of the attributes
we're breeding for okay and so this is
their their salad where it is
essentially the what you might have left
over on your cutting board after you
make a salad and so it is broccoli stems
carrot peel you see the leaves from some
of the brassicas that actually do make a
fine salad these are they're all edible
parts and this was celebrated in a salad
at sweet greens where it ran for a wild
is really looking at even as we have the
harvested of plant parts that come in
and whether we are not we choose to use
them how can we be able to change our
approaches to be able to use more of
that and so you know there's part of it
that can happen through culinary trends
and how consumers the public approaches
what to do with the produce they bring
home and it can be you know introduced
to them in these ways but also for me as
a plant breeder we start been
increasingly starting to think about so
what about all these other components of
the produce that I'm not selecting for
so I'm always selecting for the best
fruit quality and as I try to get over
the hurdle the trombone chino and how
that was something that wasn't really
fitting with my concept of what I was
going for in a butternut squash we're
going for a straight next small really
sweet then to be introduced to this long
windy squash it and it took a little
while for me to be able to really
realize the potential of doing the
breeding work within how
release it into the food system in a
more sustainable choice so looking at
the under appreciated components in this
salad the part where it's kind of come
home to some of the breeding and
selection I've been doing is I find
myself going through a squash field
tasting more parts of the plant than I
ever would have imagined even a year ago
then barber started to tell me how it
was you know I should be doing this and
how we would be you know and how there's
this potential to breathe for the flavor
of the stems of a squash plant the leaf
petioles and again this was something
where he helped me really kind of think
more broadly about what we could be
selecting for and for me the what
converted me was sampling the dish so
the nearest to me is a cue carpet people
penne pasta where there is the leaf
petioles of the squash plants that are
prepared if you look for a gluten-free
pasta now this is 100% gluten-free it's
just the leaf petioles but you know
there's variation within squash so some
actually don't taste very good some are
okay and some actually do have good
flavor and so as I've gone through the
field and doing oscillations one of the
key places you can really see this can
impact sustainability is at the end of
the season here's a panorama of a squash
field and you can see on the side
nearest me on the right you see the
typical loss that plants are succumbing
to powdery mildew even the spider
breeding efforts at some point they
senescent go down there's also some
other species from other parts of the
world that I have growing on the Left
these are naturally adapted species and
some of the the breeding work we start
to do with them and you can just see
they are still green vibrant growing
this was at my house in
October you could only imagine it a
little bit more milder part of New York
they would have been growing just fine
probably up until maybe well today last
night and so this is a poem you know so
the ground is being used it's being
planted growers can harvest the fruits
but you know at the end of the season or
as they are just having a succession of
plants there's really a lot of food out
there in the field and so as we've gone
through and learned how to be able to do
some of the sampling or kind of realize
that this is a great thing that we can
do you know it you can only have some
some benefits and so there's also an
emphasis on Lawrence right so I learned
this from a chef you know and so this
sort of approach in some of the
cultivars we're using it's something
that's not new to the world and so in
many parts of the world you know this is
part of the culture this is part of the
cuisine these plants are eaten the whole
plant in many other different countries
and so for us it's been a matter of kind
of learning those cultures learning
those traditions appreciating the value
they have and how it contributes to
sustainability food access and those
parts of the world and just kind of
really starting to enjoy and celebrate
those opportunities and for us of course
as a plant breeder there's also as we
look into some of these crops they're
growing much warmer parts of the world
still there's an opportunity to adapt
them to more thrive in our parts of
northern North East it will be very
different from where they're originally
grown right but so this is learning from
other cultures kind of getting some more
diversity in and being able to
appreciate some of the the plants now as
they are as they come from many
different places of the world and
there's definitely some breeding that
can be done but also as value as they
are and so the kind of some of the
themes I try I wanted to focus on today
is its
be able to be have a more efficient
breeding process you know there's an
opportunity cost and waiting until
something is finished and restricting
ourselves to this is exactly how it
needs to look in the marketplace so what
what diversity what potential is there
to have uniqueness and how can it be
used to actually drive consumption and
so increasingly some of the approaches
we use as we look and how to take
something that's working well now and
just get ready access to a grower so on
farm trials as pilot production and so
as we start to do our own farm trial
work there's often an idea that whoa Kay
it'll be available later when it's
commercialized as we can commercialize
some of the cultivars some of the
breeding lines that are actually doing
well now that gives growers immediate
access to it we're not gonna have them
risk their whole farms to it but they
can certainly be able to take a portion
of their land and be able to have
something that might work better and
work into more land for it as we
continue to improve it and that's
because it's before it's finished
cultivars there's often some value
reading for reduced waste learning from
other food cultures on you know what are
the other plants parts of use how are
they consumed what makes them delicious
how can we be able to look at what we're
growing and be able to apply some of the
same and also maybe try some of those
cultivars here to see what we can do to
introduce those and with that as we can
get some culinary trends led by a chef
to look at how we can be able to take
those cultivars or adapted now are
working really well and be able to
hopefully start some culinary transit
can embrace that diversity because those
are things we can eat now that will have
a much greater sustainability
even before the breeding process starts
here and to really embrace the breeding
process that's been going on for the
many years to get it to the state it was
as we experienced it from those other
parts of the world and so with that I
like to thank the graduate students in
my lab I showed clay
work Lauren Brazil ski former postdoc
Brian lucky and a fantastic group of
graduate students and postdocs in the
lab some great technical support to make
everything come together and a big
thanks to chef Dan barber at Blue Hill
that's really led us as we've learned to
explore things explore vegetables a
little bit more bravely than we were
before and lots of great collaborators
that have helped us that have helped or
we've helped with some there's aspects
of I've shown and a great support from
USDA nifA
and some other funders thank you
nope yeah yeah yeah yeah it's from 2012
to 2017 yeah sure did I skip one well no
so we're getting two generations a year
there this so the the cucumber we can
get multiple generations a year we can
even squeeze it to three and and yeah
and so that's what really helps us be
able to push it forward quickly yep
Zack and then Marcus yeah
yeah and I guess maybe I should repeat
the questions and so the question about
if there is hazards in rushing something
to a grower and if there might be some
more durable resistances other progress
so I think the it is in kind of rushing
it to a grower I think the the
considerations are you know they might
be losing production out they might have
given up on a crop completely as we talk
to some growers in the southeast they've
given up on summer squash zucchini
entirely and so in that system being
able to share something that might work
and we won't suggest so plant their
whole farm too that that would be a huge
risk but you know to put in a row and
see how it does and so it is really
those exploratory plots kind of getting
them at a scale an appropriate scale
where they can be introducing them to
their production and also at the same
time then they have enough to test
market and kind of and start to be able
to build their following before they
take something new and novel and
introduced in a large scale so it does
have to be balanced but I think it works
and Marcus
yeah and I think it's in terms of you
know culinary trends you know start so
kale was it you know so that's chef
driven trend you know I think the baby
leaf lettuce you know and how that's a
like similar to the teas and so you know
that's something that provides law so
loft to a salad so as we moved away from
iceberg lettuce to all these baby greens
it's something that's actually much more
sustainable for a grower it gives them
more some opportunity so you know how
many farms do we see now with high
tunnels that are growing greens
year-round and they're not just doing
one market class or type you know they
have multiple different species families
brassicas are being mixed in and so
there's great diversity at least going
in and so you know that's something that
got a lot of its push from the chef
community yeah any questions in Geneva
yeah
well the well we have been working with
some seed companies that are can kind of
see a real critical a way to address a
need now and so some of these are are
ending out in more regional seed
companies that do not need to have you
know thousands of pounds of seed but can
do it at much smaller scale and be able
to kind of get it out now so as we have
field days throughout the southeast its
attended by many of the southeast seed
companies many of those are picking up
so these varieties now is it they can
see it's starting to work well in a
region in need and their seed production
can also be kind of their last proof in
the trial so but yeah so it's otherwise
it is yeah being able to convince
someone to take the plunge and something
radically new that's why we need
somewhere the pull through help sure
anything else from Geneva before I move
to a couple here yeah Hey Bruce
yep yep
yeah sure and and I I didn't focus on on
it here
there's a campaign I did a talk in plant
breeding couple weeks ago they're really
focused on much of that and so that
should be up on YouTube now so again for
the people on the screen at home it'll
be hopefully in the list there but so a
lot of the work we're doing there is so
genomic selection is a really great in
promising tool for us right now and so
we've been doing genomic selection for
quality and winter squash the next step
is store ability because we'll have that
the whole debris the whole crop cycle is
one year to be able to fully evaluate
the storage of those to go from and when
we plant them to when the last ones come
out of storage and so that's going to be
a huge help we will be looking at the
true the games we've been able to make
next summer but so far it's it's very
it's very promising and we're seeing the
games being made and so and again that's
one that kind of fits in as we've had
the intermediates in the genomic
selection process we've been
distributing a lot of butternut squash
from that which are all I think
hopefully being received very well and
so they're already high-quality they are
diverse there's mixtures of fruits sizes
and some qualities and shapes but
there's still very high quality produce
and the other majors with the stripe
kubera beetle starting to look at the
genomic context so what is the reason
for that subspecies difference in in
beetle preference and we've been
focusing on f2 populations by parental
populations because the population
structure for an association study
precludes that we are studying the sub
structure and so we had to mix that up
but so we've done that coupled with
starting to look at RNA seek to see what
and using some of the new 3-prime
quantitative methods to look at
you know the gene response for beetle
feeding and what's going on between
those you kurby tason's and also just
some other volatiles and other maybe
anti feed and metabolites and the thing
that we're very proud of and I was just
accepted this morning the powdery mildew
resistance that was famously done by
Henry Munger here at Cornell 4q
cucurbits so moving the wild species
introgression from the Q curve Itamar an
easy I into Mossad ax and pepo and a key
attribute and much of the brain has been
done here so we're the first to have a
published publicly available marker
that's so far completely Co segregates
with the trait and we were very excited
about how we did that approach because
rather than creating a lot of
populations for ourselves we just took
advantage of the populations that were
already there and so as we had that
resistance gene that Henry Munger did
and shared throughout the world dozens
of breeding companies hundreds of plant
breeders working on that for probably
millions of meiosis and as we've been
able to just genotype what's resulted
from that the one region they share in
common is a 75 KB interval about 75 KB
with a couple really promising candidate
genes and we're now following up so
those are the types of studies we're
doing
it's a via another video that kind of
summarizes all those but and this was
really just looking at some of the the
art behind it and some of the other
opportunities to change how we do what
is otherwise and kind of an established
pipeline thanks Bruce
yeah Rachel
mm-hmm yeah this is the zucchini say
that that subspecies yeah
mm-hmm
yeah so yeah so the question here was as
we're crossing these two and we are
trying to go toward being able to put
the non-preference from the summer
squash into the more consumer preferred
market class of the golden zucchini how
are we going to know when we're close
enough so that will be something that
will be on part up to kind of consumers
and as we're sharing some of the
intermediates with growers if they are
being in a market there are some subtle
flavor differences there are some other
characters who might come along for the
ride we can it will probably in the end
just be a match of the visuals if we
kind of converted it over but and also
you know there are some culinary
differences that we can also rotate will
taste a lot of squash yeah thanks is a
time for remote yeah
yep
yeah and so there's a conference in 2013
that really helped get a lot of that
going and kind of a much greater
visibility to the potential there so
yeah it's increasingly you'd see the the
chef breeder interaction going which has
been really exciting and you know it's
it's a way to be able to you know
capture the creativity from both sides
and be able to work directly so there's
actually two ends of the process that
are coming together and Hannah did use
the other okay you know and I think then
the the thing I'd be arguing is to what
extent can we do to move beyond that of
it and so and just have it so what other
is people think about creating new
market classes is kind of it when is
something just great as it is and Ken
Hakeem can introduce that and that was
with the honey nut squash you know a
miniature butternut squash was not not
something that really fit into the
market is small and looked different in
it it tasted really good but it wasn't
until people really got introduced to it
that they got popularized
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu